[Musique]
c'est l'heure de journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir la mise en garde du
président en exercice de la cedeao aux
militaires au pouvoir en guinée le
président de la guinée-bissau fonds marc
ou sissoko est mballo a averti d'une
transition de 3 que qu'une transition de
trois ans aux rites inacceptable et non
négociable pour l'organisation ouest
africaine une déclaration la veille de
la tenue d'un sommet de la cedeao à new
york extraits de l'entretien accordé à
france 24 et rfi dans un instant et puis
au sénégal la justice a confirmé la
condamnation de barthélémy dias maire de
dakar il écope de deux ans de prison
dont six mois ferme dans une affaire
d'homicide qui remonte à 2011 nous
serons à dakar dans ce journal
enfin la colère des marocains face au
refus des visas pour la france les
demandeurs reçoivent de plus en plus de
refus un grand nombre d'étudiants sont
concernés et risque de perdre une année
scolaire reportage à casablanca à la fin
de ce jour
de lourdes sanctions c'est ce qui attend
la guinée si les militaires au pouvoir
ne revoit pas à la baisse la durée de
leur transition c'est en substance ce
qu'a déclaré le président en exercice de
la cedeao marot sissoko et mballo à la
veille de la tenue d'un sommet de
l'organisation ouest africaine à new
york le président de la guinée-bissau a
insisté au micro de france 24 et rfi que
trois ans de transition c'était
inacceptable écouter le il répondait aux
questions de marc perelman et christophe
bouvier c'est inacceptable pour la
cedeao inacceptable et négociables ça
veut dire que si la junte maintient
trois ans là pour le coup il y aurait
des sanctions absolument absolument
n'hésiteriez pas non loool sociaux même
ça c'est innova serbes l'ont donc au
ses inconditionnels ça on peut pas
accepter ça selon le colonel doumbouya
vous échanger avec lui où là aussi les
pontons en entendant colak si j'étais là
bas comme je vous dis dès que
j'ai appris la fonction j'étais dans des
pays j'étais burkina
et en guinée conakry
on a discuté on arrivait encore c est qu
on ne peut pas dépasser les 24 mois ça c
est négociable pour la cedeao oui mais
une fois que vous avez dit ça que le
colonel doumbouya était d'accord pour 24
mois les autorités guinéennes ont
démenti l on dit 91 36 mois bon tout ça
on va le voir après demain
pendant notre sommeil là on va voir
quelles sont les dispositions dispositif
comprendre par rapport à ça une chose
que je peux vous assurer c'est
négociable de la part de la cedeao m à 6
mois
et puis sachez que demain nous aurons
avec nous sur ce plateau semaine gaoual
diallo porte parole du gouvernement
guinéen on évoquera avec lui la question
de la transition et le sommet de la
cédéao
est justement lors de ce sommet à new
york il sera aussi question de la crise
diplomatique entre la côte d'ivoire le
mali la tension est vive entre les deux
pays depuis l'arrestation et la mise en
détention de 46 soldats ivoiriens à
bamako accusé par le mali d'être des
mercenaires à abidjan plusieurs
centaines de personnes ont défilé mardi
pour réclamer leur libération lors
envers stecher
ils défilent dans les rues d'abidjan
pour réclamer la libération des 46
soldats ivoiriens encore prisonniers au
mali
ça peut pas se passer comme ça qu'ils
libèrent cette centrale ils en
connaissent des militaires ils ne sont
pas des criminels ils n'ont rien à voir
avec la poêle malienne début juillet 49
soldats ivoiriens sont arrêtés à
l'aéroport de bamako ils sont accusés
par le mali d'être des mercenaires et de
vouloir porter atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état de son côté abidjan affirment que
ces soldats étaient en mission pour les
nations unies une version des faits
soutenu par l'onu qui admet néanmoins
une erreur de procédure dans l'envoi de
ses troupes début septembre le
gouvernement malien consentent à
relâcher trois soldats laissant
entrevoir une sortie de crise mais
quelques jours plus tard le colonel
assimi goïta déclare que la libération
des 46 prisonniers restants serait liée
à l'extradition de personnalités
maliennes vivent en côte d'ivoire une
tentative de chantage inacceptable selon
abidjan qui réclame une médiation de la
cedeao dans ce dossier le sort des
soldats ivoiriens devraient donc se
retrouver au coeur des débats lors du
sommet extraordinaire de l'instance
ouest africaine prévue ce jeudi à new
york
ce verdict ce sénégal la justice a
confirmé la condamnation de barthélémy
dias maire de dakar à deux ans de prison
dont six mois ferme dans une affaire
d'homicide qui remonte à 2011 un verdict
qui intervient dans un contexte de
tensions exacerbées entre l'opposition
et le pouvoir la correspondance à dakar
d'el menzah où le verdict était très
attendu
dans ce procès qui a été repoussée
plusieurs fois les faits se sont
déroulés en 2011 lors des violences pré
électorales
barthélémy dias était le maire de la
commune de mermoz sacré-coeur une
commune de dakar et en même temps
farouche opposant à abdoulaye wade
président de la république à l'époque
lors d'affrontements aux alentours de la
mairie un homme a été tué et selon
l'accusation barthélémy dias est le
principal responsable opposants
sénégalais n'ira pas en prison car il a
déjà purgé sa peine de six mois de
prison ferme lors d'une détention après
provisoire advance il pourrait y avoir
des conséquences politiques pour lui si
son poste de maire de dakar n'est pas
menacé il pourrait perdre son mandat de
député il a été élu lors des dernières
législatives à l'assemblée nationale si
le ministre de la justice introduit une
demande à l'assemblée nationale ses
avocats vont se pourvoir en cassation
dans les prochains jours on en vient
cette affaire au gabon guy nzouba-ndama
un opposant ex président de l'assemblée
nationale arrêté ce week end avec trois
valises remplies de billets en revenant
du congo a été inculpé pour entre autre
intelligence avec une puissance
étrangère par le parquet de libreville
quelques 669 migrants originaires d'une
dizaine de pays africains sont arrivés
dans le nord du niger parmi lesquels 14
femmes et cinq mineurs refoulés de
l'algérie ils sont arrivés à pied
assamaka ville nigérienne la plus proche
de la frontière algérienne
notre envoyé spécial à agadez harold
girard nous en dit plus
les autorités algériennes ne se sont pas
encore exprimés sur le sujet mais en
seulement deux semaines 1400 personnes
ont été refoulés à la frontière de
l'algérie vers le niger le 6 septembre
dernier c'est 847 migrants qui avait
déjà été ramené vers agadez au niger
depuis cette même frontière une option
qui est risquent de devenir de plus en
plus fréquentes la route vers l'algérie
tant le chemin qui passe par la libye
pour rejoindre l'europe est devenu
périlleux une libye qui reste pourtant
le point de passage privilégié de ces
populations ces derniers mois la
situation sécuritaire à libyenne s'est
encore dégradée avec des affrontements
entre groupes armés dans le nord du pays
et une tentative de résurgence du groupe
terroriste état islamique dans le sud
sur les centaines de départs de migrants
vers la libye depuis le début du mois de
septembre c'est 70 personnes qui ont pu
être secourus en plein désert par
l'organisation internationale pour les
migrations et ramené dans un centre de
transit dans l'est du pays
depuis septembre 2021 les conditions
d'obtention de visas pour les
ressortissants du maghreb sont
drastiques dernièrement un retour à la
normale semble effective pour les
tunisiens et des facilités sont annoncés
pour les algériens mais les demandes de
visa pour la france faite par les
marocains reçoivent toujours autant de
refus les étudiants ne sont pas épargnés
au risque de perdre une année d'études
reportage de notre correspondant jean
marie lemaire
depuis plus d'une année les refus de
visa pour les ressortissants marocains
se multiplient des mois d'attentes pour
espérer obtenir un simple rendez vous
chez tl s le prestataire des consulats
français en charge de la réception des
dossiers une démarche qui se concrétise
le plus souvent par un roger aujourd'hui
l'impatience fait place au fatalisme et
à la colère même si elle dans la
satisfaction à la demande de tous les
les formulaires de l'ambassade vous
aurez à le feu sans justification
donc elle cherche ailleurs
l'aide allait avoir un visa français la
france reproche au maroc de ne pas
vouloir rapatrier ses ressortissants se
trouvant en situation irrégulière sur le
sol français en conséquence son porte
parole avait annoncé des restrictions de
visas devant toucher principalement les
milieux dirigeants
mais depuis plusieurs mois c'est toute
la population qui se retrouvent victimes
de désaccord entre les deux états c'est
le cas de cet entrepreneur pourtant
adhérents à la chambre française de
commerce et d'industrie depuis 14 ans
malgré l'attestation de l'organisme
certifiant qu'il fait partie d'une
délégation pour un salon professionnel à
paris son visa lui a été refusé et les
1600 euros déposés à la chambre de
commerce pour ce voyage ne lui sont pas
remboursés après le refus j'ai adressé
un recours à la commission de recours
le décision de refus de visas en france
vous voyez ça par lettre recommandée
avec accusé de réception j'ai reçu
l'accusé de réception et aucune réponse
de leur part
touristes médecins artistes étudiants
tous essuyé des refus à répétition
accompagnés souvent de motifs
injustifiés
l'association marocaine des droits
humains est monté au créneau en envoyant
un courrier aux présidents macron pour
demander que les frais de dossier
s'élevant à 150 euros soit remboursé le
plus important c'est même pas le ferait
danser sur une année qui sera perdre
parce que c'est le même utilisant si
elle veut s'inscrire en espagne bien en
belgique il se trouve que les
inscriptions sont fermées parce que les
inscriptions se ferme et 30 juin donc
ils vont perdre toute une année de leur
vie tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
misé au bien on pensait qu'à travers la
france ils peuvent aller continuer
l'audit et d'après les associations de
défense des consommateurs plus de 70%
des demandes de visas serait rejetée de
leur côté les autorités consulaires
françaises n'ont pas souhaité répondre à
nos questions
vous le savez les mangroves marécages
essentiel de l'écosystème local sont
menacés par la déforestation et la
pollution ces vingt dernières années 35
% d'entre elles ont disparu dans le
monde au kenya un programme pour la
restauration des mangroves dans la baie
de gaz y cherche à inverser cette
tendance sophie lamothe
4000 arbres sont plantés ici chaque
année hamdallah bakary membres de
l'association mikko copa moja travaille
depuis des années sur la restauration
des mangroves son travail contribue
directement à l'amélioration du niveau
de vie de sa communauté
1000m c'est évident ben la forêt de
mangrove est en plein essor et l'air est
devenu plus pur au les villages qui sont
proches des forêts c'est l'un des
avantages que nous ressentons les forêts
de mangroves fournissent également un
lieu de reproduction pour les poissons
et depuis 10 ans le nombre de poissons
dans ces eaux à augmenter
[Musique]
les mangroves joue un rôle crucial pour
atténuer le changement climatique elle
retient le carbone de l'air mais surtout
le stock dans les fonds marins un énorme
bénéfice pour l'environnement mais aussi
pour l'économie calme chaque tonne de
gaz à effet serre retirer de
l'atmosphère se traduit par des crédits
carbone qui peuvent être vendus sur le
marché depuis le début de l'année les
travailleurs du projet me coco en gagner
trois millions de shillings kényans près
de 25000 euros et ils en ont réinvesti
un tiers dans la communauté
nous avons bénéficié de projets
d'approvisionnement en eau nous n'avons
plus à parcourir de longues distances à
la recherche d'eau nous avons maintenant
des robinets d'eau douce dans nos
maisons pour lesquelles nous payons des
charges moins élevées
suivant l'exemple du kenya d'autres pays
africains notamment madagascar la gambie
le sénégal et le mozambique ont lancé
des programmes de conservation des
mangroves dans le but d'atténuer le
changement climatique tout en
bénéficiant économiquement des crédits
carbone
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]